make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so continuing on with our video on
the uncanny x-men the Phoenix saga this
is when things get interesting when it
comes to Chris Claremont writing because
what he does and this is kind of summing
that I want to I want to sort of hit on
here is Chris Claremont will tell you a
story and like a whole bunch of things
will happen in that story but only one
of the things that happened in that
story will matter when it comes to the
story arc that takes place by 20 issues
down the line and that's really the way
his run his run works when it came to
like the Phoenix and the Dark Phoenix
August and the reason why I say that is
because in the earlier issues there were
a couple characters a couple concepts
who were introduced the first was the
starjammers which debuted an uncanny
x-men number 97 then we'll talk about
that here in a little while and the next
was erik the red devon Shikari now erik
the red was actually a concept that was
used by Cyclops in the earlier stories
of the x-men before Chris Claremont took
over and so like what kind of explain
how that works with regards to Devon
Shikari here in a second but what this
does is it picked up immediately in the
aftermath of basically like the Phoenix
or like the the pre Liu - the Phoenix
saga right so if you want to get caught
up feel free to watch that video but
essentially like Jean Grey is now bonded
with the Phoenix force and the space
shuttles crashed into Jamaica Bay and
when it landed down here the big
question everybody had is what's going
on with Jean because all she did was
just suddenly manifest from the water
and simply just shout you know like I'm
life incarnate I am Phoenix her whole
costume was changed the whole nine yards
and then shortly after that literally
like her mind was overwhelmed by what
she was experiencing and then she
essentially collapsed now between the
panels and what Chris Claremont doesn't
really tell us and what he kind of
relies on us to understand is that what
Jean Grey is in possession of is an
astronomical amount of power that's one
of the things that we've talked about
when it comes to the Phoenix force that
there's only one Phoenix force in the
whole multiverse and in this instance
the Phoenix force in his totality has
bonded itself to Jean Grey because the
idea was that Jean Grey was the perfect
host for the Phoenix and so almost
immediately after she collapses the
question the accident began to have is
what's going on with her is she affected
by the radiation that basically sort of
spatial crashing down into Earth in the
first place
they don't really know what to make of
all this because remember they were
basically unconscious and held in stasis
pods when the whole merger between the
Phoenix and Jean took place you know and
when that originally happened so they
don't know any of that stuff that's
going on
so of course basically it's Charles
Xavier in the x-men being whisked away
traveling out to to visit Mormon
and then you in turn like you know
figure out what's going on in your
island now more McTaggart is a character
who'd been around the x-men for quite
some time and a little bit of
explanation is needed here she's been
around the x-men for quite some time but
more McTaggart is more of a mutant
geneticist really her and Xavier kind of
work hand in hand and in fact she would
play a pivotal role and essentially like
leading into the formation of the new
mutants but the way this worked and even
with x-men deadly Genesis a story that
came decades later but really sort of
gave her a much bigger role in the life
of Xavier is that where the two were
kind of lovers at one point the idea
here was that for the most part if
Xavier couldn't understand how a mutants
powers work then he would hand them over
to Mora McTaggart she would analyze them
figure out how their power worked and
then give them back to Xavier
so he could train them adequately now of
course basically you have like you know
dr. Corbeau who comes out and says hey
look everything's gonna be cool she's
not dead she's curly just kind of
healing for whatever it was she went
through but she'll make a full recovery
and that's when things really kind of
begin to pick up and really start moving
into the Phoenix saga proper but again
what this does is it leads into an
interesting scenario because for the
most part the x-men get into a couple
different fights again into a fight with
juggernaut in black Tom Cassidy and they
get into a fight with fire Lord but for
the most part we didn't exactly know why
what is of getting explained between
issues 102 through 104 which we're
really not gonna go super in-depth into
is essentially that Eric the red had
been pitting like magneto and and
juggernaut and black Tom Cassidy and
Fire Lord all against the x-men for the
purposes of killing them and the x-men
defeated them all quite readily now for
the character of Fire Lord this is kind
of important and I want to have this
conversation for a second so fire Lord
is a guy by the name of pyrius krill
he's basically as am darian the race
that formed the nova corps is
essentially where he's from now the idea
here was that somewhere along the line
where he was basically on like an
explorer ship essentially his friend was
kidnapped by Galactus eventually pyrius
caught up with him only to find out his
friend was turned into a herald and then
died and so Fire Lord became the new
Herald in this place so eventually when
is up happening is that Fire Lord
basically travels to earth and then in
the process in Thor issues to 26 through
228 I'm pretty sure as a three-issue
story arc Thor hands a destroyer over us
the story armor over to Galactus and in
turn Fire Lord gets his freedom but the
result is that much like trying to
duplicate the success of the Silver
Surfer the Fire Lord stays on earth this
is part of the point where the Fire Lord
is sitting on earth like where he's
literally just kind of here exploring
and all that kind of stuff you know
different things like that and kind of
like understanding how humanity works
and things along those lines the issue
here is that Firelord had simply just
been duped by Eric the Red
that's really all it was the davon
Shikari had gone to fire Lord and say
hey like there's this group called the
x-men and they're led by a guy named
Xavier and he wants to like take over
the world and like enslave everybody so
like you should go and fight them and
Fire Lord essentially being a hero was
like yes so he races off and he's been
fighting the x-men the whole time and
that's really kind of where the battle
between the two of them comes from now
one of the big plays one of the big
things that where things really kind of
begin to pick up here is what's really
going on in the background is that while
the x-men are kind of distracted by
juggernaut or at least they were
distracted by juggernaut in black Tom
before they were defeated where they
were distracted by a fire Lord and
distracted by Magneto this allows Erik
the red to make his move but one big
thing that came out of this and this is
actually a pretty significant scenario
one big thing that came out of this was
that prior to this story arc magneto had
essentially been da-jin twoa into a
child and the reason why this mattered
is because it was kind of a way for
Marvel to essentially sort of reboot
magneto kind of a soft reboot for his
character and then ultimately what ended
up happening is that when Erik the red
showed up on earth or I guess when he
went to grab grab magneto he'd been here
for a while but when he grabbed magneto
he reached in back up to where basically
an age equivalent to like Xavier and all
them and that's why when you go read
Marvel Comics now Magneto despite having
been alive during World War two is not
like 90 years old right now at the same
time that all this goes on we really
kind of get this other half of the
equation which is a character named
Lalonde rrah
now we didn't really know anything about
her again some of this stuff you know
the idea of lilandra takes place before
the Phoenix saga but with lilandra kind
of popping up there were a few things
that happen with Xavier whether he was
fighting a different race the Z NOx well
whatever the case was his telepathic
powers were in a way growing and because
of the fact that there was kind of a
connection that was being forged between
himself and Alondra she was literally
like desperate to get away from her
world where she was kind of escaping on
this sort of Scout ship ultimately she
reached out to Xavier Xavier picked up
on her but didn't quite know how to
handle the situation and didn't really
know who she was
and so it's not really until this moment
in the Phoenix saga which she boards the
the teleportation device on her scout
ship and teleports directly in front of
Xavier as well as Jean Grey and a couple
other people that she basically reveals
who it is that she is like what hers
what her story is or at least to some
degree what she's about now around the
time of this happens where Xavier is
kind of understand what's going on and
so on
so forth then you suddenly got Fire Lord
attacking and then you've got Jean Grey
manifesting the Phoenix force and then
Fire Lord basically kind of like like
the two of them start you know squaring
off against each other now this was kind
of Clermont basically saying like here's
the kind of power Jean possesses now and
that's the significance of the Phoenix
saga the significance of the Phoenix
saga was kind of building the concepts
up building things up and saying here's
the power gene has here's where she's
capable of right now and then like her
power is only ever going to grow and so
for the most part she's able to hold her
own and in fact actually topple Fire
Lord to a degree but this allows Erik to
read to make his move and what he
basically does here is he kind of
reveals his assignment as being an agent
that was there was tasked to earth by a
guy named akin an emperor of the shi'ar
empire and that somewhere along the line
the laundry had come to blows with her
brother to Kim and an intern like tried
to flee the system and then the result
was that when it was established she was
trying to come to earth that Erich dread
was alerted and said hey look capture
her or kill the Etra to do whatever you
have to do but get her and bring her
back to the Shiar empire to our
homeworld so she can stand trial for her
actions and so what he basically does is
he opens a Stargate as soon as he opens
a Stargate he passes through with a
laundry and then it shuts and Jean Grae
using all the powers of the Phoenix
channels all this this cosmic energy
into the Stargate reopens it and the
x-men passed through and this leads
directly into the x-men essentially like
arriving on the planet of the Shiar
Empire now when this happens almost
immediately the x-men begin coming to
blows with the Imperial Guard and the
reason for this is because the Imperial
Guard is the elite fighting force of the
Shiar that's really what they are that
when it comes to the Shiar Empire they
are essentially like an amalgamation of
races and so what this means is that
when you have the Imperial Guard it's
literally an Imperial Guard it's a it's
an elite fighting force composed of like
some of the most capable races from
across the entire section of the
universe here in Marvel Comics and so
basically what ends up happening here is
Alondra finally spills the beans when
there's a moment of reprieve between the
x-men and all the fighting that's going
on and what she basically says is that
somewhere along the line tucán realized
that there's an artifact out there
called the m'kraan crystal
but the m'kraan crystal cannot just be
traveled to and attained right you can't
just jump into a ship fly to the far
side of the universe take the m'kraan
crystal out of its cradle and just be
like absolute power it doesn't work that
way instead the m'kraan crystal is
almost kind of in in a sort of
dimensional little small dimension unto
itself and the way it works is that if
the stars align correctly a doorway
opens once every million years
and when that happens a person can pass
through the issue with this is that it's
all just legend and hearsay that the
legend says if a person can basically
take can enter the m'kraan crystal and
attain the power contained within that
basically they can go on to gain
absolute power where Chris Claremont
doesn't really explain it here we can
because we kind of have the benefit of
like all the stories that came after and
in in a small little miniseries really a
kind of a maxi series called Adventures
of the x-men what Marvel did is they
established the idea that the m'kraan
crystal is essentially a hallway of
doors that when you enter the m'kraan
crystal you can actually access other
universes but inside the m'kraan crystal
is a city unto itself now the issue is
that if the m'kraan crystal is pierced
or in some way damaged or destroyed
it'll literally suck in the entire
multiverse unto itself and that's what
happened in the adventures of the x-men
in the the multiverse prior to this this
current one that the m'kraan crystal was
damaged by the dweller and darkness and
when that happened it basically started
sucking in the universe the multiverse
the whole nine yards and then everything
was recreated afterwards and that's
what's best was that's literally the the
legend or the story that lilandra hits
on but doesn't actually specify but
that's what she's afraid of that
essentially like the Kin will either
gain absolute power or he'll screw up
and destroy the entire universe in the
process and so with this whole fight
kind of going on between these two
groups that's when the starjammers come
in to come into the equation now the
starjammers are still ambiguous here
right they've only been around for like
a handful of issues for something like
four issues and even then they only kind
of appeared for a short time so the
basis behind the starjammers and
particularly Corsair has not been
revealed yet so those are you guys who
do know the the basis behind this please
do not spoil it in the comment section
but the starjammers are really just
space pirates that's really it but there
is an actual history here between
between Corsair and the other members of
the x-men that that like again we'll hit
on in a later time but basically what
ends up happening here is as kind of a
repeat of what we saw much later on in
the adventures of the x-men when after
the m'kraan crystal was pierced in that
particular story the Phoenix tried to
unite the minds of all beings in
existence in order to basically stop
this the result was that the m'kraan
crystal couldn't be stopped the
destruction of the crystal and the end
of the multiverse could not be prevented
but of course Jean Grey doesn't know any
of this and so literally what she does
with with the in front crystal and
everything and literally like with this
power kind of manifesting the way that
it is with him being snatched directly
to its location in this little visible
dimensional area the one is up happening
is release kind of pulses that are sent
out and when these pulses get sent out
for a fraction of a second
everything ceases to exist and then then
comes back so imagine if Thanos like
snap his fingers and snapped again and
that's basically what happens you know
every single time a pulse is sent out by
the m'kraan crystal now the reason why
this pulse is sent out is because one is
the m'kraan crystal emanating itself and
two because this is basically the
arrival of Jaffa I always thought it was
JA ok the way this works is that because
the m'kraan crystal contains such
extreme power that like a huge concern
would be what if somebody just walked up
and took it and then just like ran amok
in the universe and so what ended up
happening is there was basically a kind
of security system put in place that
there was an agent a protector of the
m'kraan crystal and what is up happening
is that this this guy jaw literally
starts like crushing all of the x-men
like just starts running through and
essentially just like wrecking almost
every last one of them
but Banshee is the one who figures it
out what bad she realizes is that
basically Joss made this sort of this
statement about being programmed that he
was programmed for the purpose of
protecting the m'kraan crystal
if he's programmed it means on some
level he's a robot and if he's a robot
he's got the mechanical components and
so what Banshee ends up rationalizing
here is that all really really has to do
is just run upon job and then you
literally use this for his sonic screams
you'd like disrupt all the mechanical
components and that's exactly what he
does he disrupts the mechanical
components of java which basically
destroys him and then they're met by mod
and what in the way this works is kind
of a cool revelation the way this works
is that there's Jeff who's the first
guardian Jeff is the one who basically
protects the m'kraan crystal
if Jeff is destroyed then mod will show
up and motts power is 1,000 times the
power of Jeff if mots destroyed then the
next guardian will be 1,000 times the
power of mod and it will keep going on
it's an infinite continuation of power
until the individual who's there can be
destroyed now this is kind of the cool
caveat to it is that the design of this
security system was to basically create
kind of a dual riddle kind of a riddle
of sorts is you face off against the
Guardians and they keep getting
astronomically stronger but they also
get astronomically larger each time the
bigger they are the easier they are to
get around
and so they're really more of a
distraction to distract you from the
reality you can actually just run upon
the crystal because they're just so
astronomically big and that's exactly
what happens is the x-men take in all
these different guys basically end up
running up on the crystal literally
entering the crystal itself and when
they do is like this infinite expanse of
space there's also confining at the same
time with a city on the inside now this
is a
essentially the white city the city of
like the white phoenix of the crown
chris claremont will not really
establish this until we get into the
Dark Phoenix saga but that's basically
what this is it's the city in the center
of the m'kraan crystal that the Phoenix
resides here it basically exists here
that whatever the Phoenix is not
manifesting itself in a different
universe whenever it's not doing
anything and it's going back to its base
of operations so to speak to rest this
is where the Phoenix force goes this
center of the m'kraan crystal and so
again it's kind of a cool thing because
when this happens like literally there's
a kind of security system here you know
again another stage of effect here and
one is up going on is that as they
approach it they're all basically met by
like a nightmarish experience but
literally all they do is just see the
worst of their nightmares so again it's
designed to basically keep people at bay
now the issue with this is that Jean
Grey as the Phoenix is really the only
one who can actually walk up on the
m'kraan crystal and is not affected by
like the force of the the security
systems which again is really kind of
chris claremont way of saying like she's
supposed to be here and so when she goes
through here and she starts analyzing
the in chronic Risto and figuring out
what's going on what she basically
starts doing is talking about like a
like a latticework and different things
like that and for people who are reading
through that it can seem very confusing
so the easiest way to think about it is
like this the m'kraan crystal can has it
has a huge source of energy and
basically it's like this small little
neutron galaxy on the inside basically
like if the in chrome crystal were to be
pierced everything would be sucked in
what stops that from happening imagine
like a chain-link fence running around
the m'kraan crystal so long as that
fence is there and it contains the
energy of the improv crystal everything
will be fine the issue is that with the
crystal being pierced that chain-link
fence is now damaged which means that
power is leaking out it's like having a
pinhole leak in a wall with like a
gazillion gallons of water behind it
right like with all that pressure it's
only a matter of time before it blows a
hole in the wall and that's basically
what Jean Grey is realizing here this
lattice work is damaged but because
there's so much power confined behind
this lattice work even though it's like
a small little tear it's a small little
piece of damage it's only a matter of
time before all this energy just
explodes outward and then starts sucking
everything in and so what she ends up
doing is kind of banning the spirits
essentially if like all the x-men
together and then using the power of the
Phoenix to essentially go through and
like repair this lattice work and what
it does is essentially fix the m'kraan
crystal now this is why this is so
important because for so many kind of
looking at this and just sort of
skimming through it the reality is that
it doesn't really seem like anything
happens the reason why is because the
truth of the of the Phoenix saga is that
it's a pre lured the Phoenix saga is a
prelude to the Dark Phoenix saga the
Phoenix saga is basically designed to
say okay guys so like Jean Grey is
astronomically powerful now but like
what would happen if she became a bad
guy but that's basically what it is and
like all the stories to take place
between the Phoenix saga and the Dark
Phoenix saga are designed to focus on
that design to lead up to it so like the
Hellfire Club and all those different
things so on and so forth is all
designed to lead into that but this
story is so significant because it was
designed for the purpose of basically
taking Jean Grey who is one of the
weakest characters of all time and then
throw her into becoming the most
powerful member of the x-men and in fact
one of the most powerful beings in the
entirety of the Marvel Universe but it's
a cool story as it is a cool little set
of events the result here is that after
has all said and done
lilandra cannot return to the Shiar
empire right like she's essentially
exiled she's banished and so she's
confined to earth and ends up staying
with the x-men for quite some time the
starjammers are also a part of the
equation now which means we'll also see
some emphasis on the starjammers as a
focus on them and and the role they play
but it's again kind of a prelude so
everything that comes after this leads
directly into the Dark Phoenix saga
proper but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comment explain
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the robb core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]